not being as represented in hollywood as
i felt like
young black men should be like i felt
like we're severely underrepresented
under represented not only just black
men but just like
a lot of us and it's not just you know
basketball or selling drugs like
yes some of us play music yes some of us
are smart and get top grades you guys
you know what i mean like it's all of
that unless we come in different shapes
and sizes and all of that too
congratulations on this show i mean it
is intense but it is so impactful it's
real time real issues
i don't have all the answers
but to be honest it matters who you talk
to
what drew you all to wanting to be a
part of grand army
i don't think any of us would have
expected ever being a part of something
like this when we were
so young there's no way to expect
something as
yeah crazy and amazing as this
but what drew me to it was like just
definitely the writing
first and foremost i remember again
getting the sides and just
reading the script and being like wow
this is really authentic in a way that
um is extremely rare at least for me
like
it was no question like anything katie
touches i'm like
i know that's gonna be genius and
groundbreaking and beautiful and i want
to be a part of it in any way that i can
see in the script and at least for at
least for me like it's everything y'all
just said and
but for me it's like the extra layer of
not being as represented in hollywood as
i felt like
young black men should be like i felt
like we're severely underrepresented
under represented not only just black
men but just like
a lot of us and it's not just you know
basketball or selling drugs like
yes some of us play music yes some of us
are smart and get top grades you guys
you know what i mean like it's all of
that yes
we come in different shapes and sizes
and all of that too so that was really
important for me
when i got the sides i knew it was going
to be big because
dom is a first generation haitian girl
growing up in brooklyn
and i felt like that was as my first big
role that would be easy to tap
into because you know i'm first
generation
and like if this career all there i
would love to speak some creole you know
and like
i felt like it was an easy fit so i
really wanted to be part of it but
then i also felt like maybe i'm not that
like you know
i don't have any experience on camera
and maybe i'm
like i don't have much experience
auditioning either so
i felt like maybe
it wasn't for me but i'm here now
and i am grateful and the process was
amazing and
what made me want to really be part of
this was
knowing that a first-generation haitian
girl was going to be
like a lead in this so well girl let me
tell you
you shine you all do and i love that you
use the word groundbreaking
because i feel like this show is going
to
help a lot of young adults feel
seen in so many different ways i mean
this show we see
peaceful protests we see the fight
against social and racial injustice
we see teens navigating relationships
friendship
sexual identity for you guys was there
anything
that maybe you spoke with the team about
incorporating
into your own character storyline that
may have not
been in there to begin with but meant a
lot to you
personally the characters are like
pieces of us
you know like we've all we these are all
people that we know from our everyday
life you know what i mean
so it's like you take those experiences
and you draw those to
the situations that are going on in the
show and everything is so
like like it's so beautifully written
and if every character feels so well
rounded and so well versed
it's almost like it doesn't feel like it
needs anything more you know at least
for me i don't want to speak for anybody
else but it doesn't feel like
it needs too much more just you as a
person just
portray it i guess and then when it
shows through you that's what it is you
know
odessa i feel like for you in particular
i mean you've always used your platform
and you've always been so vocal for
social justice and i feel like your
character
is very similar to that as well yeah she
definitely is i mean we
um she likes to highlight
issues different issues than i do and we
get different hate from it
but yeah i'd say we're both pretty vocal
on our social media
platforms i feel like at the end of
grand army we see how everyone's
characters have
really grown is there a conversation for
a season two
i don't know is there a conversation
netflix this you that's the question
right hey let me know i'm like i'm ready
to get paid again
we're ready